ساعه قليله ويستيقظ غول اسعار جديد بازمه
جديده تاثيرها سريع ومباشر على حياتنا
حضروا المشتقات النفطيه المنقوله بحرا بعد
التوجه نحو فرض سقف على اسعارها سيطلق
الفوضى وهي فوضى فبراير كما اسماها
الخبراء وببلوغ هذه النقطه فقدت توسكو
رسميا سوقا ماده جذور صادراتها من الطاقه
فيها طوال خمسين عاما حظر اوروبي على
النفط والان المنتجات المكرره والغاز
قبلهما وهذا رسميا كان النفط الاسرع في
ايجاد منفذا بديل عن اوروبا وجهه مليونين
ونصف المليون برميل يوميا من خام موسكو
قبل الحرب الاوكرانيه فماذا عن المشتقات
منتجات اما بعد تكرير النفط الخام
كالسولار مثلا
طوي عام 2022 على شحن
220 مليون برميل من الديزل الى الكتله
الاوروبيه من الموانئ الروسيه فهلا ستجدوا
طريقا اخر او ملاذا بعد اليوم ومن المتضرر
بهذه الحاله المصدر المستورد
بالنسبه لروسيا هناك تحدي لكنه واعد لو
ابحرت المشتقات على خطى النفط الخام
بالاتجاه سيكون الى امريكا اللاتينيه
واسيا وافريقيا لكن للهند دور مفصلي النفط
الخام الروسي الذي بدا يتدفق اليها منذ
يونيو الماضي حل مكان النفط العراقي في
سته اشهر
اقتنست نيودلهي غالبيه الشحنات بعد ان
قدمت موسكو خصومات خياليه وصلت الى 40% اي
ما يعادل 35 دولارا للبرميل والربح هنا
مزدوج فما تكرره الهند في مصافها تبيعه
باسعار مرتفعه لاوروبا ونتحدث عن كم
730 الف طن متريا شهريا منذ بدايه الحرب
هذه هي خديعه كبيره لكن الخديعه الكبرى
تتم في الولايات المتحده في نيويورك ومنذ
بدايه يصل يوميا
89 الف برميل من البنزين والديزل الهندي
هي اكبر كميه خلال اربع سنوات تقريبا لكن
يفسر ذلك النقصان 28 مليون برميل عن متوسط
السنوات الخمس من نواتج التقطير الامريكيه
بما فيها الديزل والهند اسعفت الولايات
المتحده الكميه متوفره لديها بل والفائض
عنها بكثير ففي نفس الفتره اي منذ بدايه
يناير مليون و400 الف برميل النفط خام
روسي بلغ الاستيراد اليومي لي من الهند
الى الولايات المتحده وفقا لشركه كابلر
ولا يستثنى طبعا من كل هذه المعادله لا
تستثنى تركيا تستطيع هي الاخرى سد
احتياجاتها من الديزل الروسي تكرره وتبيعه
بسعر السوق لاوروبا
هذه التحويله بغض النظر عن نقطه الالتفاف
فيها تطرح تساؤلات حول جدوى العقوبات
روسيا تصرف منتجاتها بكل الاحوال وبخلاف
ذلك اسعار الطاقه في العالم سترتفع خبر
غير صار تنبا به بنك اوباميركا يقول ان
مجرد حظر المنتجات البتروليه الروسيه
سيرفع اسعار الديزل الى 200 دولار من سعره
المسجل في نهايه العام الماضي
128 دولار
اجراءات دول السبع على النفط والغاز
الروسيين ان شكلت ضربه موجعه للاقتصاد
الروسي تتمثل في خساره السواق ضخمه لصدره
روسيا من الطاقه بعد بدء سريان قرار موسكو
حول حظر تصدير نفطها مطلعا شهر الجاري
حولت روسيا منتجاتها البتروليه الى اسواق
بديله في السوق الاسيويه بما في ذلك عن
طريق البحر ولكن باسعار اقل من السوق
العالميه ابرز الدول التي تتصدر قائمه
مشتري الذهب الاسود الروسي هي الصين
والهند وتركيا وباكستان وبعض دول وسط اسيا
خطوه تاتي وسط صعوبات تقنيه من اجل اعاده
توجيه الصادرات خاصه مع الاضطرار الى
توسيع خط انابيب قوه سيبيريا الذي يصل
بالغاز الروسي الى الاراضي الصينيه